it's a big week for Adam Schiff and
Democrats running the impeachment
spectacle after their hearsay sham
failed to deliver they're now set to
call eight new witnesses over the next
three days a Nancy Pelosi is taunting
president Trump daring him to testify
check this out
president could come back before the
committee and talk speak all the truth
that he wants if he doesn't expect it if
he wants to take the oath of office or
he could do it in writing he has every
opportunity to present his case but it's
really a sad thing I mean what the
president did was so much worse than
even what Richard Nixon did President
Trump firing right back saying he likes
the idea and would strongly consider it
Trump also continuing to call out
impeachment witnesses over the weekend
Pelosi responding with this cheap shot
he should not frivolous we throw out
insults but that's what he does I think
part of it is his own insecurity as an
impostor I think he knows full well that
he's in that office way over his head
and so he has to diminish everyone else
Wow impostor while Pelosi and shift plow
ahead one Democrats warning that the
party's impeachment obsession is tearing
the country apart what I'm hearing out
in the street is with most people is
they're kind of tired they're kind of
worn out they're kind of bored we spend
millions of dollars in my opinion tons
of money tons of time tons of hurt
fraction the nation apart I haven't seen
this to be a good thing are you hearing
these things out in the street
[Laughter]
thankfully he was silent Peters out of
town I think I spoke to a total of five
humans in 48 hours I last week just did
me in I was quiet but I read a lot I
read a novel of course that you would
course like and I watched a little bit
of the coverage just so I could keep on
top of things I feel like going into
this second week the Democrats already
have the burden of proof and it's a
really high one and last week I don't
think that they met it because
and just from their own admission in
their own coverage in their own
headlines if you read a lot of the
coverage or if you even listen to some
of the podcasts where they're talking
about how the Democrats felt after
Wednesday's testimony in particular was
like oh gosh I don't know are we gonna
be able to keep this going they continue
to tell the same story over and over and
over again it's a short period of time
and I think that people coming to the
consensus that this is not impeachable
whether you thought it was appropriate
or not approachable appropriate there is
an election happening in less than 12
months from now and that's where people
should make the decision I think that's
where things are at the moment right it
seems like they could have handled this
with an oversight hearing Gregg
absolutely you know actually I was on
the street yes looks like it's up there
yes was a rough weekend and I talked to
a lot of people Dana I've got two four
thousand people around Florida two
thousand drive and I'll tell you this
you may we may be required to air but
you are not required to care who I am
tire the natural resentment that I'm
seeing by the media who are hectoring
the public about their obligation to
take this farce seriously all right
the media is shoving this down your
throat it would blanket abysmal coverage
and then they scold you for not
genuflecting before their altar of
solemn news this is historical they tell
you no it is hysterical
again the resentment the media holds for
anyone who doesn't swallow their garbage
is repugnant you should give them the
metaphorical finger to all of this
because these are the same people that
implored you to take the dossier
seriously to take collusion seriously to
take the anti Cavanaugh mob seriously
they've been wrong every time it's all
garbage you know what you can do
I would binge watch by the way our
ratings are great so I think we can say
this we could take one for the team
binge watch like the Rockford Files or
Botox
Bojack horseman go on like Netflix our
mother loved Mort
that's terrible modern love makes me
sick have a person of interest
who
that's a good show I say something now
no because listen I want to speak okay
I'm tired take a rest
here's the thing Dana you're not you
said when you said that they have that
they haven't met their burden of proof
yet here's the bottom line they shifted
the burden of proof Nancy Pelosi gets
out there and she says mr. president
come on and improve your innocence
this is America you don't shift the
burden of proof and say to the to the
Jews although he isn't even accused yet
we don't know what he's accused of but
we know we're gonna get him look at what
John Dean said he should have been that
he should have been a pizza first day
hey John are you stupid
you're a lawyer give you know what yeah
can you teach them on the first day he
hasn't done anything yet these people
have said that he should come in and
prove something truth to power they're
nuts they're bonkers and you know what
they we ought to stop giving them press
on this stuff because nobody cares
anymore it's a bunch of hogwash it's a
bunch of telephone it's a bunch of
rumors hearsay get over it Wow I still
think it's important to cover it so that
you can actually call them out I'm on
either side but I think if you don't do
that yeah there's there's only you know
one place where you can so don't watch
the Rockford Files okay I don't know
first three seasons are rising one would
you like to respond yeah there's so much
to responsibility second what I do do
get the impression that what you the
right is saying is here oh please don't
watch don't pay attention to impeachment
you'd be smart to go watch whatever
Rockford Files or whatever but here's
what the reality is like reality is that
the ABC News poll this weekend 70
percent of Americans think that the
president requesting that a foreign
leader get dirt on his political rival
is wrong it's how the question was
framed why you don't mind if I finish no
I do 1% 51% of majority American people
slight but still a majority say not only
impeach Trump but remove him and get
this 21 percent in this ABC poll said
they're not paying that much attention
so that should please my table my
colleagues know if you know what the
people who were paying attention for the
first week 66% to
said impeach and remove you know what
they're doing they're doing something
that they don't have to pay for they
don't have to buy a political end
they're trashing the guy every day I
want to jump in for one thing because
you mentioned these polls we have polls
that show like 70 percent of Democrats
think Trump sawr Russian agent there's a
lot of people out there brainwashed by
the mainstream you know what Trump is
suffering from full employment like here
we have the lowest unemployment in
history so they can't watch the people
that are working can't watch the
hearings brought so many Americans back
to work they can't watch this brainwash
going on intention he should have had a
terrible economy so they could have all
watched the impeachment hearing I can
watch it from jail Oh Roger stone the
best people in jail all the Trump's guys
economy's so good even Colin Kaepernick
[Laughter]
Dana I want to get back to over talking
about earlier about the people in this
country are fatigue even independence of
tune this thing out the new york times
over the weekend did a thing they don't
even know what to believe anymore after
the rush of collusion to bring up that
New York Times piece this morning are
not posted last night but basically it
said that there's so much information
too much information nobody is
understanding following the whole story
nobody trusts the media I should say
nobody but a lot it was it was a sizable
they think only 15 percent of
Republicans or conservatives they
trusted media is 65 percent of liberals
that's even at 65 percent that's a
pretty low number so basically what it
said is there's so much stuff that's
been thrown against the wall people are
not paying
attention to any of it and they're
figuring they'll just wait until the end
maybe find somebody that they trust read
a couple of places that they feel that
they can believe in and make a decision
at that point but right now my mom she's
in Taos and Santa Fe and they're like
taurine and little caves and
hieroglyphics and all this stuff and
they're not paying attention to this
stuff looking good all the evidence is
in the transcript you don't need
anything else it is the best record of
what happened where people